[موسيقى]
أول ما يتبادر إلى
أذهاننا هو "القاعدة" ، كان هناك
فهم
للتهديد ولكن لم يكن على رأس
قائمة أولويات أي شخص
[موسيقى]
مجتمع الاستخبارات لا يفهم
كل شيء بشكل صحيح لا يفعله "  لقد
عانينا من الحكمة الإلهية خسارة كبيرة
في حزننا وغضبنا ،
وجدنا مهمتنا
ولحظتنا
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
كنا دائمًا نتبعه من أجل
إنشاء أرشيف كبير لصوره
حتى كان لدي ذلك اليوم
الكاميرا
وأردت
فقط التقاط المقابلة ،
كنا أربعة أشخاص ، وأنا
صديق آخر ،
وهذان العربيان ،
سألهما القائد من
أنت ، كيف أتيت إلى
أفغانستان ، ما نوع الأسئلة التي
لديهم على الأقل سؤال واحد هو
أنه إذا أخذت  فوق أفغانستان ، ما الذي
ستفعله مع القاعدة
وزعيم القاعدة
وأنا كنت مشغولاً بالكاميرا الخاصة بي ربما لمدة
15 و 20 و 30 ثانية
حتى سمعت صوت انفجار
لم يكن الصوت قوياً
كما هو الحال عندما تكون كرة القدم  انفجرت ،
ثم عندما نظرت إلى الوراء إلى
المبنى ، رأيت أن جميع الأبواب
والنوافذ قد تحطمت ، لقد مروا ،
كنت مع جدتي كنت جالسًا
معها وكنا نتناول الطعام
كانت أختي
معنا أيضًا
وأخذت ملعقة  أكلت
ثم سقطت من يدي
وفجأة كان هناك اندفاع من التوتر
والأدرينالين والأوعية
الدموية
وعبثا وكنت
خائفة وخائفة حقًا
وسألتني جدتي عما يحدث لك قلت
إنني لا أفعل  لا أعلم ولكن لدي هذا
الشعور الغريب الذي حدث لأبي
في اللحظة المحددة عندما وقع الهجوم
والانفجار على بعد
مئات الأميال والكيلومترات
من مكان وقوعه
[موسيقى]
هبطت المروحية
رأينا مبنى المستشفى الكبير
وكان هناك  مبنى آخر على مسافة
كانت المشرحة والسيارة
بدلاً من التوجه نحو المستشفى ،
تحولت نحو العلامة وأنا
أعلم أنه في ذلك الوقت
لم يعد على قيد الحياة
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كان يعمل مع طالبان مباشرة من  في
بداية الأمر ،
كانت القاعدة تفكر في أن
الاستفادة من الموقف
قالوا إنهم سيكون لديهم نوع من
القاعدة الدائمة في أفغانستان ، لذا كان هناك هذا ، كانت
الأيديولوجية هي نفسها
الأساليب التي كانت إلى حد ما هي نفسها
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
[موسيقى]
أم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
واتصلت على الفور بمساعد
السكرتير المساعد لمكافحة التجسس
وقلت إننا نتعرض للهجوم
وبعد حوالي دقيقتين
اتصل نائب الرئيس وقال
من فضلك اذهب إلى غرفة المؤتمرات الآمنة
نحتاج إلى إجراء مكالمة فيديو
ولكنني
على الفور  أدركت أنه في أعقاب
اغتيال أحمد شاه
مسعود
أن الولايات المتحدة وبالتأكيد
أنا مذنب
بفشل الخيال
[موسيقى]
نعم بالطبع
كانوا يستمعون
ولكن لا يوجد عمل
الأشخاص المسؤولون عن تسعة
أحد عشر شخصًا هم نفس الأشخاص الذين تعرف أنهم
كانوا مسؤولين عن اغتيال والدي
عندما دخل هذان العربيان إلى
أراضينا ، كان ذلك قبل 15
يومًا تقريبًا من
9 سبتمبر ، مما
يعني أن الخطة كانت
للمساعدة في اغتيال
القائد
قبل
9 سبتمبر
إذا نجحوا.  للقيام بذلك ،
سيكون
لديهم
ما يكفي من الوقت
لتنظيف أفغانستان
قبل 9 11.
يمكنني أن أخبرك أنه كان ممتعًا
لأنه عندما
قُتل كان طالبان مبتهجًا
للغاية واعتقدوا أن
هذا لا بأس به بدون مسعود أخيرًا
'  سأنتصر في الحرب وما إلى ذلك وما إلى
ذلك ،
لقد جندت مصدرًا كان عضوًا في
القاعدة
أه
لذلك قمنا بتجنيده بالكامل وذهب للعمل
لدينا
ثم تم إجباري لاحقًا من قبل
مقر وكالة المخابرات المركزية على أنني يجب أن  قطع
الاتصال به والتوقف عن مقابلته
بشكل أساسي لأنه كان مواطنًا في
بلد كانت لنا معه علاقات ودية
وكانوا قلقين أكثر
إذا تم القبض علينا ونحن نقابل هذا الرجل
بشأن احتمال أن يؤدي ذلك إلى إتلاف
العلاقات الدبلوماسية أكثر من وجود
مصدر داخل آل.  - قايدة ،
لذلك اضطررت إلى قطع الاتصال
عندما كان في أفغانستان ، كانت هناك
خطط عملياتية كاملة مكتوبة داخل
وكالة المخابرات المركزية
للذهاب إلى أفغانستان
والتخلص منه ، حيث كانت
الخطة الأصلية هي
أننا سنذهب إلى أفغانستان
وسنذهب  لقتل هذا الرجل
لأنه يستعد لقتلنا
لأنه يقتلنا بالفعل
ولم تتم الموافقة على تلك النباتات أبدًا
كان هناك مع عائلته أه كان من الممكن أن يكون
هناك نساء وأطفال
قُتلوا بالتأكيد كجزء من
تلك العملية
بادال  هادية ،
أريدكم جميعًا أن تعرفوا أن
أمريكا اليوم
على ركبتها منحنية
في الصلاة من أجل الأشخاص الذين
فقدوا أرواحهم هنا ،
يمكنني أن أسمعكم أن بقية العالم يسمعكم وسيسمع
الناس الذين هدموا هذه المباني
جميعًا.  قريبًا في
اليوم التالي لـ 11 سبتمبر ، بالتأكيد خلال 24
48 ساعة من ذلك ،
عدت إلى مقر وكالة المخابرات المركزية
وأنت تعلم ، ثم كان هناك الكثير من
الغضب الذي
تبعه بسرعة كبيرة ،
هل يمكننا نزع القفازات الآن
ويمكننا الآن أن نفعل كل شيء  من بين الأشياء التي
كنا نحاول أن تجعلنا
نفعلها
كما لو كان قد فات الأوان ، فقد مات آلاف الأشخاص ،
لكن هل يمكن الآن السماح لنا أخيرًا بإنهاء
هذا
الفيديو ،
أتى شخص ما من مركز مكافحة الإرهاب
للتحدث معي
وسألني  إذا كنت أعرف كيف يمكنهم
الاتصال بهذا الرجل وأين
يمكنهم العثور عليه ،
فهذا سؤال سخيف ، صحيح أنه
كان إرهابياً ، ألم
يكن صديقي ،
ألم يكن أخي ،
لم نبقى على اتصال اجتماعيًا ،
لم يكن يعرف حقيقته أبدًا  من الواضح أنك
لا تتسكع مع
مصادر إرهابية ، فأنت لا ترسل لهم بطاقات عيد الميلاد ،
حيث يكون جيدًا إذا كان بإمكاني تخمين أنه
موجود هناك الآن لتنظيم
عمليات متابعة لقتل الأمريكيين ، هذا ما
أظن أن
لدينا وكالة استخبارات رائعة
نحن  ما زلنا غير أفضل استخبارات في
العالم ولماذا لأنه لا يتعين علينا أن
نكون لسنا
إسرائيليين ، فنحن لا نتعرض للهجوم
من جميع الجوانب ، فنحن
مجتمع ديمقراطي حر مفتوح مع
حدود مفتوحة إلى  تعال إلى الجنوب تعال إلى
ما يمكن أن يحدث خطأ هنا
وفجأة اكتشفنا وجود الشر ،
عليك أن تتذكر في التسعينيات أننا كنا
نحتفل بعائد السلام ، لقد
سقط الجدار ،
قللنا من ذكائنا ،
واستثمرنا تمويلنا
لاستخباراتنا  المجتمع الدولي بشكل جذري
فجأة اكتشفنا أنه
ليس لدينا ما يكفي من المتحدثين العرب ،
ليس لدينا عدد كافٍ من المتحدثين باللغة الفارسية ، ليس
لدينا متحدثون باللهجة ،
نعم ليس لدينا ما يكفي مما نحتاج إليه
إذا كنت محقًا ، فأنت تقول كل ذلك  هذه
وأعني هجمات 9 11 كان يمكن منعها
دون أدنى شك أنه كان من
الممكن منع
[موسيقى]
حزننا قد حول الغضب
والغضب إلى حل
سواء كنا نقدم أعدائنا للعدالة
أو نحقق العدالة لأعدائنا ،
سيتم تحقيق العدالة ، وكان القرار الأول هو
إعطاء  لطالبان فرصة
لتسليم أسامة بن لادن
والقاعدة وكانت الرسالة الأولى
لطالبان في أفغانستان أنه إذا فعلت ذلك
يمكنك البقاء في السلطة ،
فلديهم مهلة قصيرة جدًا أوضحوا
أنهم لن
يسلموا أيًا منها.  من قيادة القاعدة ،
وبالتالي فقد تبع ذلك حتمًا
أننا سنقوم بعمل عسكري ،
كل دولة
في كل منطقة لديها
الآن قرار لاتخاذها
إما أن تكون معنا
أو مع الإرهابيين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أنت